did you guys did you see this no
oh barricade garage is another hit i
love this guy
good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to the most trusted name
and
news here joining us tonight for an
interview
is a white supremacist i'm not a white
supremacist though
i'm not a white supremacist look at me
i'm not even white i'm a waffle colored
american
you're not even 20 seconds sir and
you're already
fake news you're sir you are a white
supremacist because you support trump
bro i'm not a trump supporter i'm
a bk i'm the guy that'll put you in a
pine box and then play bass guitar at
your funeral
that's me but since you want to talk
about white supremacists
i know trump supporters aren't white
supremacists cause no self-respecting
white supremacists
would support a president who gave his
daughter to a jew
barricade garage coming uh it's a bit
shoot very very soon
i
i love him yes me too i know i know i
i mean whoo he like you gotta understand
is like you know me and royce are on the
list we've said a lot of wild [ __ ] on
this show
he still says [ __ ] sometimes it makes me
go
whoo you know we just suck in air and go
wow
dude i would wow okay we're going there
self-respecting white supremacists would
support a president who gave his
daughter to a jew
so if you want to talk about white
supremacy at least get your facts right
will you at least publicly condemn the
january
6th insurrection at the capitol
that wasn't an insurrection no
politicians died which makes that
a failure
yes dude the [ __ ]
dude he is the [ __ ]
oh don't try to get me cut off no no no
no i had
[ __ ] hack your security system boost my
antenna to match your frequency
so i'm not going nowhere unless i want
to go
so let's talk about some things since
you want me to condemn something
how about you condemn that picture bill
clinton in a blue dress
in red hills they came out of epstein's
house how come y'all not investigating
that
how about you condemn your reporters but
not investigating that we still want
answers
on that since you want to condemn some
[ __ ] how about you condemn this fake ass
virus hoax
that's a trojan horse for the
sustainable development goals of agenda
21 laid out by the united nations
i love it i love it he has said more
things in this two-minute video
that would [ __ ] get you killed off of
this [ __ ] site
that people have done in entire episodes
well development goals of agenda 21 laid
out by the united nations
and spoiler alert the germ theory is
false
but you don't want to talk about that
now do you because your big
farmer's propaganda are and would you
like to condemn
bill gates for his solar geoengineering
project
to block out the sun effectively causing
cold snaps
like what happened in texas all while
politicians
place the blame on climate change yeah
let's talk about it
let's talk would you also like to
condemn joe biden telling black people
that they don't know how to use the
internet
dude he is he's pushing it man
barricade garage ladies and gentlemen
he's pushing his luck
barricade garage he's pushing his luck
jesus christ
oh buddy that's twice he said
politicians
you can't keep things going keep getting
away with it
that i mean i mean that's awesome but
god damn dude even i'm always even i'm
like i'm more careful than he is
nowadays like even i won't say [ __ ] like
that i'll imply it
i'll joke about it of course like he's
just straight up like
he's just saying it politicians